So here's the answer. What we have to do is
find these two double quotes. So we know that we
want to start looking from start_link, we can't start from the
beginning of page. So we want to use find on page, passing
in the double quote, which is what we're looking for,
starting from the start_link position. So here's how we need to
do that, we're going to initialize the variable, start_quote, which is
where that double quote that starts the url is. And what
we want to do is use page.find, to find in page.
The string that we want to find is that double quote. To
make a double quote as a string, we need to use
a single quote, followed by a double quote, followed by a single
quote. We also need to pass in a second parameter. We
don't want to find the first double quote in the page, because
that might not be part of a link tag. So we
also need to pass in the variable start_link. So that makes find
start from the position of start_link look for the
double quote, and it will return the location where that
start quote appears. We also need to find the
end quote. We'll call that end_quote. To find the end_quote
we don't want to start from the start_link. If we
started looking from the start_link we'd find the start_quote again.
To find the end_quote we need to look starting
from after the start_quote. So we're going to use page.find again.
Again looking for a double quote, so passing in
the double quote as the string we're searching for. We
need to start from the position of start_quote. We
can't start from just the position of start_quote. If we
started from start_quote, we'd find just the start_quote itself.
We knew to start one after that position, so we
need to add 1 to start_quote. And if we start
looking from there, we'll find the first quote after that.
That's the quote that ends the string. So the final
thing we want to do, is set the variable url.
So we'll initialize url, to the string that we find
between the start quote and the end quote. And so
we can do that using the string selection. We're selecting
from the string page. We have to think carefully about
where we start. We don't want to start with a
start_quote because that would include the double quote in the url.
We just want the url not including the
double quote, so we're going to start with the
start_quote plus 1. And we're going to go from
there until the end_quote. We don't want to include the
closing double-quote. We don't include that one in the
string. So we don't need to subtract 1 from
the end_quote. And that will get us the url,
extracted from the first link on the web page.